vieja práctica que sea popularizado en
Argentina en la Plaza de Mayo en Buenos
Aires los habitantes se reunieron para
una sesión improvisada de intercambio a
gran escala bajo el lema el salario ha
muerto vuelve el trueque los ciudadanos
encuentran su manera de luchar contra la
galopampa inflación estamos cambiando
acá lo que sería mercadería por ropa
zapatillas por alguna otra prenda de
ropa un poco más nuevo un poco más
grande es más que nada como para
que el gobierno vea en la situación en
la que estamos que ya no nos alcanza o
sea el salario que nosotros tenemos no
no nos alcanza para nada los precios en
los supermercados aumentan semanalmente
y están minando tanto los salarios como
los ahorros de los ciudadanos en un país
que depende mucho del dólar y en el cual
la gente ya no confía en los bancos
algunas personas eligieron intercambiar
productos contra estos tickets No hay
plata y tenemos que hacer pero hay que
comprar con esto intercambiar no entre
nosotros lo que tenemos si bien
Argentina logró reducir levemente la
tasa de pobreza en el primer semestre
del año la indigencia creció y los
sectores más vulnerables sufren
particularmente los impactos de la
inflación la tasa de pobreza urbana
seguía alcanzando el
36,5% de la población en el primer
semestre del año pero se prevé que la
inflación ronde el 90% interanual para
finales de año el ministro de economía
Sergio Maza que tomó posesión el 3 de
agosto tiene como misión principal de
reforzar las cajas del Banco Central ya
que Argentina necesita urgentemente
dólares para financiar las importaciones
y pagar su deuda